bonjour et merci d'être avec nous ce
matin sur rtl france ce coup d'état
militaire était-il prévisible alors que
le mali est confronté en rappel depuis
des mois à une grave crise socio
politique
en tout cas je sais pas si elle était
prévisible en tout cas c'est pas
vraiment une surprise comme votre
journaliste dont le sujet précédent l'a
rappelé ebayi bk le président donc être
contraint à la démission aujourd'hui
était lui-même arrivé au pouvoir
élu à la suite du coup d'état de 2012
orchestrée par à l'époque par le fameux
capitaine sanogo en mars 2012
et je vous rappelle que six mois plus
tard six mois après ce coup d'état de
2012 les djihadistes du nord-mali décidé
de foncer sur bamako et ensuite c'est
l'histoire franco malienne qui
recommence avec l'intervention de cerval
donc voyez c'est pas une surprise en soi
ce pays est habitué
cela fait plusieurs mois depuis mai juin
dernier alors que là que la cour
constitutionnelle avait invalidé une
trentaine de d'élections législatives
celle d'avril dernier qu'une opposition
forte s'était constitué contre contre yb
eca et son gouvernement avec un
personnage d'ailleurs dont on n'entend
pas parler aujourd'hui mais qui est
central dans le jeu malien c'est le
fameux imam mahmoud dicko qui a été
longtemps président du haut conseil
islamique malien qui a été également
pendant longtemps un soutien politique
du bk et qu'il a lâché en 2017 et qui a
joué un rôle très important ces
dernières mois ces dernières semaines
pour fédérer l'opposition
enfin trois oui bonjour prix alison est
ce qu'on peut aller jusqu'à dire que
c'est cet imam dont vous parlez qui a
renversé le président ibrahim boubacar
keïta qui derrière ce coup d'état
epic un lien aussi quels liens avec le
mouvement du 5 gens qui vous le
rappeliez même la contestation populaire
malienne depuis plusieurs semaines non
on joue on sait pas encore exactement
quels sont les responsables de ce coup
d'état mais on voit bien qu'il ya deux
niveaux de la contestation je le
rappelais ya un niveau politique et cet
imam a joué un rôle pour fédérer les
différentes
mouvement de contestation politique et
pour créer ce fameux mouvement du 5 juin
que vous rappeliez slash rfp un
mouvement rassemblement des forces
patriotiques
ça c'était la contestation politique
dans la rue et on voit aujourd'hui c'est
là où les choses ont basculé c'est que
les militaires sont sortis du bois comme
on dit il ya plusieurs éléments qui
peuvent expliquer ce ce déclenchement
ligne a notamment le fameux rapport du
conseil de sécurité de l'onu qui a fuité
ces derniers jours dans la presse et qui
accuse là l'équipe qui est sortante
comment dirais-je d'être de ne pas avoir
su rétablir notamment mettre en place
des accords de paix il ya on va on va
savoir dans les prochains jours
exactement qu'est ce qu'il en est mais
voyez il ya 2 2 de niveau il ya un
niveau politique et à un niveau
militaire et dans ces pays là évidemment
le niveau militaire compte énormément
sachant que dans cette affaire l'armée
est elle destituer le président elle l
est également
elle n'est pas sans tache sans faute
depuis plusieurs années depuis plusieurs
mois en particulier dans la guerre
contre le terrorisme elle est accusée
d'exactions régulière par la population
donc l'armée accuse aujourd'hui bk de ne
pas avoir su rétablir l'autorité de ne
pas sortir du népotisme mais l'armée
elle même n'est pas en est également sur
le banc des accusés alors justement
l'armée ou en tout cas les militaires
qui ont pris le pouvoir en premier une
transition politique et des élections en
général tous les accords internationaux
seront respectés distille quel est votre
regard est ce que ces annonces ont de
quoi rassurer bon quand quand la cedeao
dit qu'elle va fermer ses frontières
en tout le monde sait qu'en afrique les
frontières sont poreuses donc c'est une
déclaration formelle le quai d'orsay
pour l'instant parle de mutinerie c'est
dire qu'il est prudent il attend de voir
de quelle façon on va tourner cette
cette affaire-là en tout cas ce qui
paraît assez évident c'est que l'équipe
actuelle va sortir tout ce qui va le
l'essentiel de ce qui va jouer dans
l'est dans les prochaines heures c'est
la manière dont les militaires mutins
pour reprendre le mot du quai d'orsay
vont asseoir la transition politique
qu'ils promettent une transition
politique civile
en tout cas on a des raisons d'être
fortement inquiet bamako est en quelque
sorte la base arrière des la guerre
contre le terrorisme au mali dans le
sahel
sur son flanc est il y à l'opération
marque anne des français barkan qui
luttent justement pour contre ce
terrorisme et dont l'un des objectifs
était de mettre à niveau la menace entre
guillemets pour la transférer aux états
africains et notamment aux armées
africaines et est également de pouvoir
restaurer l'autorité de l'état dans
l'est dans les territoires contestés
on voit bien que si à bamako la capitale
du mali
les choses sont compliquées alors
imaginez bien comme quelle peut être la
difficulté pour l'opération barkan qui
se trouve finalement pris à revers en
quelque sorte
merci beaucoup mériadec raffray d'avoir
pris le temps de répondre à nos
questions ce matin je vous aime je
rappelle que vous êtes journaliste et
spécialiste du mali